[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها بالعناوين
ساعات على بدء الهدنه في السودان باريس
تثمن جهود الرياض وتدعو لتطبيقك
علي وريانه على بعد خطوه من المحطه
الدوليه وترقب لاكتمال مناوره الالتحام
الفضاء السعوديان يتحدثان من الفضاء الحلم
يتحقق وشكرا على التمكين
اصول التوام السياميه السوريه احسان وبسام
الى الرياض تمهيدا لعمليه الفصل المقرره
لهما
وموجه برد في جنوب السعوديه تعيد
التساؤلات حول المناخ الايام موجته طقس
عابر ام تغير
قبيل ساعات من دخول الهدنه حيز التنفيذ
مساء اليوم شهدت العاصمه الخرطوم مواجهات
بين الجيش والدعم السريع وافادت مصادر
خاصه للعربيه بان الجيش السوداني اطلق
قذائف مدفعيه ثقيله باتجاه مناطق التمركز
قوات الدعم السريع في الخرطوم ياتي القصف
المدفعي مع تواصل اعمال العنف والمعارك في
انحاء العاصمه وسمع ايضا دوي انفجارات في
مناطق متفرقه من بينها منطقه الصحافه
وقد ثملت الخرجات الفرنسيه دور السعوديه
والولايات المتحده للتوصل الى اتفاق وقف
اطلاق النار في السودان الذي يستمر مده
اسبوع بدءا من اليوم وجددت فرنسا دعوتها
لكل الاطراف الى تطبيق كامل لكل البنود
والى احترام وقف اطلاق النار لضمان امن
المدنيين والسماح بايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه
قد ارتفع عدد ضحايا نزاع المسلح بين
المدنيين الى 863 قتيلا واكثر من
3500 جريح ذكرت نقابه اطباء السودان ان
العديد من الاصابات والوفيات غير مشموله
في الحصر بسبب صعوبه التنقل والوضع الامني
في البلاد
بعد نحو 20 دقيقه من الان تكتمل مناوره
الالتحام مع محطه الفضاء الدوليه لمهمه
رائدى الفضاء السعوديين عن القرني وريان
برناوي على متن المركبه
انطلقت يوم امس من مركز كندا الفضائي في
فلوريدا في مهمه فضائيه يشارك بها ايضا
رايده فضائل اخرانهما
من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
من المركز الموحد للمهمه السعوديه الى
الفضاء في الرياض ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي حياك الله عبد
الرحمن كيف تجري الان عمليه المتابعه اللي
مناوره الالتحام بمحطه الفضاء الدوليه
نعم خالد الجميع هنا على هبه الاستعداد
لهذا الحدث التاريخي والمهم بالنسبه
للسعوديين وايضا بالنسبه للعالم العربي
والاسلامي بحكم ان اول رائده فضاء عربيه
ومسلمه موجوده على متن هذا او هذه البعثه
الى الفضاء طبعا اكتمال هذه المناوره خالد
سيتم تحديدا الساعه الرابعه و24 دقيقه
بتوقيت السعوديه اي تقريبا بعد عشرين
دقيقه بالتمام والكمال طبعا فتح باب
الكبسوله
ليخرج
الرائدين الى المحطه سيكون تقريبا الساعه
السادسه
وربع بتوقيت السعوديه مساء اي تقريبا بعد
ساعتين بعدين حيكون في خالد احتفاليه
لاستقبال الرواد في تقريبا الساعه السادسه
وخامسه 45 دقيقه بتوقيت السعوديه ومن ثم
هناك كلمتين
رايدي الفضاء السعوديين على متن المحطه
ومن ثم تبدا هذه المهمه التي تضم العديد
من المهام المتنوعه فيما يتعلق بالبحث
طبعا خالد هناك ايضا استعداد كبير من قبل
السعوديين من جميع المده هناك معرض اقيم
لهذه المناسبه في مركز اطراف الظهران وفي
الرياض هنا ايضا وفي جده لاطلاع السعوديين
والشعب السعودي وايضا المقيمين على تفاصيل
هذه المهمه التاريخيه التي من المتوقع ان
تضيف الكثير
للتاريخ السعودي وايضا هناك اهتمام كبير
من قبل الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء لاستغلال
هذه البعثه لتعزيز
الفضاء بالنسبه للاتصالات وتقنيه
المعلومات وايضا استخدام الانترنت بكافه
اشكاله نعلم ان الاجيال القادمه بالنسبه
للانترنت خالد لن تكون عبر الابراج التي
نراها الان بل هي ايضا ستكون عبر محطات
فضائيه فالمستقبل كله هناك في الفضاء في
السعوديه امتدادا لهذا المستقبل تقوم بهذه
المهمه خالد ايضا من المعلومات المثيره
للانتباه خالد بان مرحله الالتحام مع محطه
الفضاء تقريبا 16 ساعه منذ انطلاق
المكوك حتى وصوله الى المحطه ومن ثم سيقوم
الطاقه في مركبه دراغون بعمل مناوره
باستخدام انظمه الدفع بحيث يتم الاقتراب
اكثر والالتحام بالمحطه سادع زميلي ماجد
ياخذ بعض اللقطات لهذه
المركز الذي نحن موجودون فيه الان خالد
هذا المركز ايضا من مهامه هو متابعه هذه
الرحله التي خالد يعني تقريبا
استغرقت اكثر من سته عشره الساعه ومن ضمن
خالد المهام الملقى على عاتق رائدي الفضاء
ابحاث حول الاستمطار في الجاذبيه الصغرى
ايضا هناك تجربه حول علوم الخلايا خالد
ولا ننسى ان ريانه هي متخصصه في المجال
الصحي وتحديدا
المختبرات هناك ايضا
سيكون بث مباشر
للتجارب توعويه حول الجاذبيه الصغرى طبعا
خالد من المهم ان نعلم بان هذه الرحله في
غالبيتها ستكون متاحه
وموجوده على الهواء مباشره
لمشاهده تفاصيلها اولا باول بالنسبه
للسعوديين وم تابعه
محطات هذه الرحله وفتراتها ومراحلها لم
يعني معرفه تفاصيل هذه الرحله واكتشافها
اكثر فاكثر فالسعوديين هم جزء لا يتجزا من
هذه الرحله يصح التعبير خالد برفقه رائديه
الفضاء شكرا لك حتى الان عبد الرحمن
العصيمي من المركز الموحد للمهمه السعوديه
الفضاء بالتكييف سنعود اليك حال بدء مرحله
الالتحام بالمحطه محطه الفضاء الدوليه
في فيديو ايضا بثاته سبيسكس سيتحدث كل من
رائدي الفضاء السعوديين ريان برناوي وعلي
القرني للمره الاولى منذ انطلاق رحلتهم
المتجهه لمحطه الفضاء الدوليه على متن
المركبه
اللهم لك الحمد والشكر الحمد لله على غرفه
الحمد لله على اللحظه التاريخيه اللي
نعيشها ما هو بس انا اعيشها احنا وانتم
سويه استمتعنا صراحه بالاطلاق ولم اتاكد
انكم انتم استمتعتوا بالمشاهده
شكرا لكل من دعمنا شكرا لمن كل من وقف
معنا وساعدنا شكرا لمن وصلنا لهذه المرحله
شكرا لسموخ سيدي خادم الحرمين الشريفين
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز شكرا لولي عهده
الامير محمد بن سلمان على هذا الدعم
والتمكين والثقه فينا كشباب طموحين برغبه
بلهفه ان نحقق المستحيل باذن الله مع
دعمكم وتوفيقكم اهلي انا في الفضاء الحلم
تحقق اللهم لك الحمد والشكر وقريبا ان شاء
الله في المستقبل القريب الكثير سوف ينضم
لنا ان شاء الله ونراكم قريبا من محطه
الفضاء الدوليه
احب ابدا الشكر بقيادتنا
وصاحب الرؤيه ولي عهدنا محمد بن سلمان على
دمه لهذه المهمه شكرا للهيئه السعوديه
للفضاء شكرا اكسيون شكرا شكرا
على تدريبهم لنا طبعا شكرا لست لعائلتي
الجميله واصحابي ورواده فضاء السعوديين
علي الغامدي ومريم فردوس على دعمهم فهذه
الرحله لابناء الوطن الغالي نحن الان في
عصر التمكين والازدهار بفضل الله ثم
قيادتنا الحمد لله نحن الان وصلنا عنان
السماء
فكلنا نحتاج نسويه انه نحلم باذن الله
ونشتغل على احلامنا وباذن الله راح نوصل
الى العاصمه السعوديه الرياض قبل قليل
التوام السيام السوري احسن وبسام حيث سيتم
علاجهما في مدينه الملك عبد العزيز الطبيه
للحرس الوطني بعد اخلائهما من العاصمه
التركيه انقره عبر الاخلاء الطبي الجوي
هذه العمليه هي السابعه والخمسين التي
تجريها السعوديه ضمن جهودها لفصل التوام
السيامي او التوائم السيامي بقياده المشرف
العام على مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه
والاعمال الانسانيه الدكتور عبد الله
الربيع
او ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه هاني الصفيان
هاني مرحبا بك
الان نلتفي سياره ربما الاسعاف التي تقل
التوائم السيامي السوري كلمنا اول شيء عن
طبيعه حاله بسام واحسن
نعم اهلا بك يا خالد واهلا بمشاهدين قناه
العربيه اذا فريق العربيه يرافق البعثه
الطبيه في مدينه الملك عبد العزيز
الطبيه وبوزاره الحرس الوطني هذه المركبه
الان التابعه لوزاره الحرس الوطني وهي
مركبه اسعافيه تقوم بنقل التوام السيامي
بسام واحسان ولذين وصلاه
الى مطار الملك خالد الدولي ويتم مراقب
مراقبته الان صحيا من قبل الفريق طبي
وكذلك متخصص حتى يتم وصولهما الى المستشفى
وبعد ذلك سوف
سوف تقوم فرق طبيه اخرى
بمسانده هذا الفريق الطبي
وتوجههم ما الى
الغرفه الخاصه بهما عموما والده التوام
السيامي الطبي بسام واحسانه موجوده الان
وبينما الصور تلتقط او الصور الخاصه التي
تلتقطها الكاميرا العربيه لبسام واحسان
سوف التقي بوالده بسام واحسان مرحبا بك
اولا في السعوديه ومرحبا بك ايضا في هذه
المركبه الاسعافيه ونحن نتحدث اليك اولا
دعينا نتحدث عن التفاصيل بسام واحسان كيف
عرفت
عن التصاقهما يعني في اي شهر
والفرق الطبيه اللي عالجتك هناك ماذا
اخبرتك
اهلا وسهلا فيكم الله يجزيكم الخير
وبسام واحسن انا ولدت بسام واحسن ومن
عمرهم شهرين اكتشفت انه ملصقين وقالت لي
الدكتوره يعني وان شاء الله له العمليه
والله ما في اكرم منه ومن عند من عند
الولادهن حولوني على تركيا حولوني على
تركيا والحمد لله رب العالمين اعتنوا فيهن
دخلونا المشفى وطلعوا هون هون لبين ما صار
عمرهم سته شهور قالوا لي بدهم يعني
رعايه الام رعايه امنا حويناهم بالبيت
وقالوا لي بصير ان شاء الله عمليه بس لبين
اربع سنين خمس سنين كرمال لبين مشان احسن
مريض يعني احسان هو اللي انا اعاني من
مشاكل صحيه اكثر الحمد لله رب العالمين بس
ما في شيء بس احسن يعني نقصر
شويه يعني كم عمرهم الان صار عمرهم سنتين
ونصف الان كيف عرفتي عن انه والله في فريق
طبي سعودي او برنامج
سعودي لفصل التوامسانيه في السعوديه من
اللي يدلك وايش الاجراءات اللي اتخذتيها
هنا
نحن عن طريق صديق يعني عرف وضعنا وشرحنا
له هيك الوضع وربع للسفاره السعوديه
والحمد لله رب العالمين اعطانا رقم من
المشفى وتواصلنا معهم والحمد لله ما قصروا
والحمد لله رب العالمين ادوا يعني
اجراءات كانت الاجراءات الحمد لله رب
العالمين نترجى من الله هيك يعني الله قدر
واحساني يعني المستشفى انا بعطيك نبذه عنه
وبسيطه هو اجرى 56 عمليه فصل والحمد لله
كانت ناجحه هل انت وش تعرفين عن هذا
البرنامج وايش تعرفين ماذا اللي سمعتي عنه
عن المستشفى الملك عبد الله التخصصي او
البرنامج السعودي
والحمد لله رب العالمين العمليه عم تنجح
معها هون والحمد لله رب العالمين الله
يجزيه الخير اذا
هذه العمليه او هذه الحاله هي رقم 134 في
تاريخ برنامج السعودي
للتوائميه خلال الثلاثه 33 عاما برنامج
السعودي
اشرف على اكثر من 133 حاله حول العالم
قام بفصل اكثر من 56 او قام بفصل 56 حاله
من 23 دوله خلال 33 عاما قد تكون هذه
الحاله هي رقم 57 بعد الاجراءات وبعد ايضا
الفحوصات التي سوف يقوم بها الفريق الطبي
وتحديدا البرنامج السعودي الفصل التوام في
مستشفى الملك عبد الله التخصصي بمدينه
الملك عبد العزيز الطبيه بوزاره الحرس
الوطني في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض مراسل
العربيه من الرياض
في الرابع بعد قليل
موجه برد جنوب السعوديه تعيد التساؤلات
حول المناخ هل هي موجه الطقس عابره ام
تغير دائم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد لا تزالوا مناطق متفرقه
من السعوديه تشهد حدوث حالات مناخيه نادره
منها تساقط الثلوج واستمرار الامطار
الغزيره كان من اخرها ما شهدته محافظه
خميس مشيط الواقع في جنوب غرب البلاد قبل
نحو ثلاثه ايام من تساقط كثيف لحبات البرد
نتابع بعض ما تم توثيقه عبر عدسات كاميرا
سكان هذه الاحياء
[موسيقى]
من عنيزه ينضم الينا نائب رئيس جمعيه
الطقس والمناخ الدكتور عبدالله المسند
حياك الله دكتور عبد الله دكتور اللي
نشوفه في خميس مشيط او اللي شفناه يعني
انا شوفوا لاول مره ربما تكون مشاهد نادره
الحدود يعني طبقات من الثلوج المتراكمه
على الطرقات يصل سمكها في بعض المناطق الى
نصف متر تقريبا اللي حاصل سببه اننا امام
حاله مناخيه استثنائيه مرتبطه بالتغير
المناخ في العالم ام انه حاله عابره حاله
طبيعيه لا تستدعي القلب
بدايه اخي خالد اسمح لي ان نهنئ خادم
الحرمين الشريفين ولي عهده الامين والشعب
السعودي والعربي والامه الاسلاميه
بنجاح هذه الرحله التاريخيه لرائدى الفضاء
السعوديين واسال الله سبحانه وتعالى لهم
الحفظ والسلامه والتسديد والتوفيق هذا من
جهه من جهه السؤال حول الصور التي تم
عرضها دائما اكرر الصور التي تصور للبرد
غالبا يكون فيها تدليس وغالبا يكونوا فيها
عدم دقه بمعنى ان الله سبحانه وتعالى من
رحمته لا يسقط البرد وحبات البرد على
الانسان بهذا الحجم وبهذه الكتل وبهذه
الاوزان
ويبدا المصور والمتابع بتصوير المواقع
التي تجمع
لحبات البرد ايه هذا اللي قالوا يعني هو
نتيجه تراكم لحبات البرد سببت هذه الطبقات
الثلجيه او الكتل الثلجيه صح الصور
في اكثر من موقع في الواقع والبرد الذي
نزل في خميس مشيط واكثر من موقع الى حد ما
يندرج تحت الوضع الطبيعي لهذه العواصف
الرعديه التي تتكرر غالبا في المرتفعات
الجنوبيه الغربيه بحكم وجود جبال الثروات
ومن ثم هذه الجبال تقوم
بحجب وحجز الرياح الرطبه القادمه من الغرب
الامر الذي يبنى فيه السحب الركاميه التي
فيها مصانع البرد وخاصه في قممها ومن ثم
تنزل هذه الحبات البرد وتختلف احجامها من
حاله الى اخرى
ويجدر دكتور يعني احنا ممكن نشوفها هذه او
شفناها في المناطق المحيطه بجبال الثروات
يعني زي ابها وغيره
خميس مشيط منطقه داخليه يعني كما يقول
الاهالي الخميس يعني ما شافوا مثل هذه
المظاهر في مرات سابقه بهذا الحجم بالتالي
هل له علاقه بالتغير المناخ العالمي
لا يوجد اي الحقيقه صله ما بين التغير
المناخي وما حصل في خميس مشيط خميس مشيط
لا تبتعد عن حافه الثروات الا كيلومترات
بسيطه جدا وتعد في قمم جبال السنوات ومن
ثم اذا تزامن سقوط البرد مع امطار غزيره
قامت هذه الامطار بتجميع حبات البراد في
مواطن
المنخفضه سواء في الاحياء او في التقاطعات
ومن ثم تاتي الكاميرات بالتصوير ويعتقد
الناس ان كل خميس مشيط او الطائف او
الرياض او جده فيها هذه الكميه او سقطت في
هذه الكميه وهذا امر لا يكون الطبيعه بهذا
الشكل رحمه من الله سبحانه وتعالى الامر
الثاني فيما يتعلق بالتحذير من هذه
الحالات الماطره تستطيع الجهه التي تمتلك
رادارات دوبلر المركز الوطني للارصاد ان
يتتبع هذه السحب الركاميه المزنه الركاميه
وقبل ان تصل الى المناطق المستهدفه خاصه
المدن في نحو 30 دقيقه يستطيعون اطلاق
التحذير والتنبيه من خلال رسائل الجوال
فتصل للمنطقه المستهدفه عبر تقنيات جدا
بسيطه وممكن ان تفعل من اجل تحذير
المزارعين وتحذير ايضا المتنزهين وتحذير
اللي دعاه مثلا الارصاد الى الى دراسه هذه
الحاله وهذا التغير كما جاء
جميل جدا ان نسمع من الارصاد انهم بصدد
دراسه مثل هذه الحاله والتي ليست هي
الاولى ولن تكون الاخيره وبالمناسبه حبات
البرد وظاهره البرد لا ننتظرها في فصل
الشتاء غالبا وانما تسقط في فصل الربيع
والخريف او في الصيف في المناطق التي تهطل
فيها امطار كما في الطائف والباحث وايضا
منطقه عسير وجبال جيزان طيب
اذا ما لها علاقه او لا يمكن مثلا ان
نعتبرها ضمن ظواهر الطقس المتطرفه خصوصا
دكتور يمكن احنا كنا تكلمنا في العام
الماضي في موجه الامطار اللي اللي في في
الامارات واللي ذهبت الى البحرين وقطر
وغيرها
اتذكر ذاك اليوم تقول يمكن انه القلب من
امتداد هذه الموجه الى هذه المناطق اللي
لم تكن تشهدها يمكن سابقا بالتالي هل يمكن
الحكم بنفس هذه الطريقه على ما نشاهد الان
من تغيرات مناخيه وخاصه انت في في صفحتك
في تويتر كان هناك ايضا بعد مشاهد الفيديو
لمناطق احتراق في بعض الاراضي يعني في
محيط جده وفي في غيرها من المناطق
اتفق معك ان ظاهره البرد تصنف بان من
ظواهر الطقس
العنيفه
[موسيقى]
وبالنسبه لتغير المناخ وارتفاع درجه
الحراره وما يسمى
سيدفع هذه الظواهر الى مزيد من التكرار
وايضا مزيدا من حجم البرد لان كل ما
ارتفعت درجه الحراره كلما كانت التيارات
الصاعده تدفع حبات البرد الصغيره لتلتحم
بحبات اخرى مطريه ومن ثم تكبر هذه الحبات
حتى تنزل بصوره قد تكون غير معهوده وخطيره
ايضا جدا وربما يصل بعضها الى حجم حبات
البيض وهذا امر ملموس وفقا للتغيرات
المناخيه وفيما يتعلق باحتراق الاعشاب او
الربيع هذا هذا العام استثنائي فيما يتعلق
بال الطامس الواسع الشاسع في معظم مناطق
الاناميه السعوديه وعندما ارتفعت درجه
الحراره يبس واصبح هشيما تدروه الرياح فاي
حريق في هذا الربيع سوف يمتد بمسافات تعد
بكيلومترات كما
شاهدتم فيه مقطع الدبدبه الشمال كم ممكن
توصل درجه الحراره في الصيف عندنا في في
المنطقه الدكتور خلال العام
انت ستبلغ كم ممكن توصل يعني
غالبا اخي خالد صيفنا رتيب لا توجد
ايقاعات
تستحق
درجات اعلى من المسجله العام الماضي
نشر اي توقعات طويله الامد لسبب بسيط
المعلومه اللي عندك دكتور
المعلومه كما ذكرت لك لا تصلح للنشر لان
مخرجات النماذج المناخيه العدديه الرياضيه
لا اثق فيها
او شهرين او ثلاثه اشهر فيكفينا الى 20
يوم فيما فوق الخمسين
او اقل
كررت في سنوات ماضيه خاصه في القيصومه
وحفر الباطن وقريب من الخفجي وقريب من
الرقعي ومن ثم الكويت وجنوب العراق خاصه
هذه المرقه المنطقه المنطقه شديده الحراره
بل هي اشد مناطق العالم حراره في فصل
الصيف شكرا لك من ان يزالنا رئيس جمعيه
الطقس والمناخ الدكتور عبدالله المسند
الرابع ايضا ولكن بعد الفاصل علي وريان
على بعد خطوه من المحطه الدوليه ترقب
الاكتمال مناوره الاتحاد
ساعه على بديل الهدنه في السودان باريس
تتمن جهود الرياض وتدعو لتطبيق كامل
للبنوت
علي وريان على بعد خطوه من المحطه الدوليه
ترقب لاكتمال مناوره الالتحام
الفضاء السعوديين يتحدثان من الفضاء الحلم
يتحقق وشكرا على التمكين
اصول للتوام الصيام السوري حسين وبسام الى
الرياض تمهيدا لعمليه الفصل المقرره لهما
وموجه برد جنوب السعوديه تعيد التساؤلات
حول المناخ موجه طقس عابره ام تغير دائم
اهلا بكم من جديد اذا تكتملوا بعد قليل
مناوره الالتحام مع محطه الفضاء الدوليه
لمهمه رائدى الفضاء السعوديين علي القرنين
وريان برناوي على متن المركبه دراغون التي
انطلقت امس من مركز كندي الفضائي في
فلوريدا في مهمه فضائيه يشارك فيها ايضا
رائده فضاء اخران هما بيجي ويستون من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
من الرياض مستشار الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء
الدكتور هيثم التويجري حياك الله دكتور
هيثم الله يحييك اخوي خالد خلينا نقف الان
على المرحله اللي وصلها
الان المركبه الفضائيه التي تحمل ريانه
وعلى القرني الان وحسب الاخبار العاجله تم
التحام
الكبسوله دراغون مع محطه الفضاء الدوليه
ربما نتابع المشاهد والصور التي تاتينا من
خلال هذا مركز التحكم في كندا دكتور
تبع ناسا في تحكم تبع سبيك تحكم تبع
اكشن سبيس طيب استمع الى الصوت الان ربما
في
العد التنازلي بدا او اذا كانت قد اكتملت
بالفعل الان مرحله الالتحام حسب الاخبار
العاجله المركبه تلتحم الان في محطه
الفضاء الدولي ما الذي يعنيه التحام
دراغون بمحطه الفضاء الدولي
الالتحام هو
زي ما تكون لما تصل للمركبه الفضائيه
الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه يكون في عده
بوابات ممكن تلتحم في احداهما بحيث انه
يصير الطاقه موجود على جوجل يستطيعون
الدخول الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه لكن قبل
ذلك يعني تحدث عده مناورات زي ما شفنا
الاطلاق امس الليل
وسبعه وثلاثين دقيقه بتوقيت المملكه بينما
الالتحام يتم الان تقريبا
يعني
المركبه او الكبسوله لما تطلع وتدخل في
المدار حول الكره الارضيه تكون على ارتفاع
منخفض حدود 130 150 كيلو بينما محطه فضاء
دوليه على ارتفاع ما بين 370 الى 420 كيلو
فعشان تصل الى هذا الارتفاع يجب انها تعمل
عده حركات دوران وهذه يعني تبع قوانين
ميكانيكا الدوران للاجسام الفضائيه
فبالتالي يعني ما تروح تتوجه للمحطه بشكل
مباشر
يجب ان تستطيع دكتور حتى بس نفهم فيزياء
على محيط الكره الارضيه وترتفع وترتفع وهي
تدور بحيث انها تتكاسب سرعه كافيه انها
تكون عند السرعه اللي فيها محطه الفضاء
الدوليه
وثم تصل الى محطه الفضائيه
في عده نقاط يسمونها
النقطه الاولى على تقريبا بعد 220 متر من
المحطه
الدوليه الهوائيه وهذا يعني النقطه تعتبر
كانك تخيلت
فقاعه
افتراضيه تحيط محطه الفضاء الدوليه بحيث
انها تحميها من اي دخول مراكب اخرى
فبالتالي اذا وصلت عند نقطه على بعد 220
يسوون التشييكات الاخرى يشوفون الاتجاهات
اي تعديلات اي مناورات صغيره عشان يدخلون
الى النقطه الثانيه اللي هي 2 اللي تبعد
تقريبا عشرين متر من محطه الدوليه لما تصل
الى نقطه
يبدا يدخل فيه التحكم الالي بحيث ان
المركبه تتوافق بالضبط مع نقطه الالتحام
ويتم الالتحام وبعد الالتحام
يعني لازم يقومون بعده
خطوات لا خطوات
اولا يشيكون قضيه الضغط هل هو متوافق بين
ومحطه الفضاء الدوليه احميتها اكدون ان
الالتحام التحام كامل ما في اي تهريب او
تسريب للغازات يتاكدون كذلك من درجات
الحراره متوافقه بين
نعم المحطه بعد ما يمرون في جميع الخطوات
وتاكدون يتم فتح البوابه من قبل محطه
الفضاء الدوليه ومن ثم يروحون
ويفتحون الباب من الكرودن ويدخلون الرواد
الفضاء طيب اسمح لي دكتور خليني بس اروح
معك للمركز الموحد الان المهمه السعوديه
الى الفضاء في الرياض ينضم الينا مره اخرى
الزميل عبد الرحمن العصيمي مراسل العربيه
من هناك عبد الرحمن
تؤكد لنا ايضا الان اكتمال التحام دريجون
بمحطه الفضاء الدوليه عبد الرحمن
نعم تم التحام الدراغون بالمحطه الفضاء
الدوليه خالد في هذا في تقريبا قبل
دقيقتين طبعا كان متوقع انها تكون رابعه
23 دقيقه لكن تاخرت تقريبا حوالي عشر
دقائق طبعا خالد هناك الكثير من الاسئله
التي يطرحها غير متخصصين في علوم الفضاء
حول تفاصيل تتعلق بهذه الرحله ينضم الي
المهندس ماجد المشاري مستشار الهيئه
السعوديه
للفضاء مهندس ماجد دعنا نتحدث عن
ماذا
يحدث الان ماذا يفعلان ريان او علي الان
وماذا سيحدث في الساعه السادسه مساء عند
وصولهما الى محطه الفضاء بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله بدات عمليه الالتحام
وبدات
المركبه دراغون والمحطه الفضاء الدوليه في
تنفيذ الاجراءات المتب
تنفيذ عمليه الالتحام والتي على ضوءها
سيتم انتقال الرواد بمركبه دراجون الى
محطه الفضاء الدوليه
ستستغرق العمليه اكثر من مئات دقيقه
تقريبا لان هناك عده اجراءات اقل من
ساعتين اقل من ساعتين نعم
لانه هناك كثير من الاجراءات التي يتم يجب
اتباعها لضمان موازنه الضغط بين
المركبه وبين محطه الفضاء الدوليه ومنع اي
تسربات ليتم انتقال الرواد بسلام الى محطه
الفضاء الدوليه ماذا سيفعلان ريانه وعلي
عند وصولهم الى المحطه وفق البروتوكول
المتبع عند وصول ايرون جدد سيكون هناك
احتفاليه صغيره بوصولهم
سيستقبلهم سبع رواد فضاء من دول مختلفه
حول العالم
ومباشره بعد ذلك سيبدا رائد الفضاء بتنفيذ
المهام
اليهم والتي تنقسم بين مهام تشغيليه ومهام
تنفيذ التجارب العلميه مباشره سيبداان
بالمهام او السيكون هناك وقت للراحه وقت
للتجهيزات هذه جزء من جزء من المهام
المخططه لانه نعرف ان كل رواد الفضاء
عندما يصلون لديهم جدول
دقيق ومفصل يشمل كما ذكرت اوقات الراحه
واوقات العمل وغيرها عمليه الابحاث
وتفاصيل هذه المهمه يستطيع المشاهد العادي
ان يتابعها سواء عبر موقع الهيئه السعوديه
للفضاء وايضا عبر موقع المحطه الدوليه
للفضاء او سنعتمد فقط على تغريدات وما
يبثهم يبثهم الرائديه ريان وعلي بلا شك
سيكون هناك مهام تواصليه لرواد الفضاء مع
مع العموم يمكن ياتي على راس تجارب
التواصليه او المهام التواصليه هي اجراء
ثلاث تجارب تعليميه توعويه مع المدارس في
اكثر من اربعين موقع يشارك فيها 12000
طالب فهذه راح تكون فيها بث مباشر وايضا
مواقع التي اقامتها هي السعوديه الفضاء في
الرياض وجده والظهران ستقوم ببث مباشر
لهذه التجارب واضافه الى العروض القائمه
التفاعليه التي يقوم بها المختصم مهندس
خالد دقائق تقريبا قليله حوالي 100 دقيقه
تفصلنا عن هذا الحدث التاريخي وصول ريانا
وعلي الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه
للبدء بمهامهما البحثيه هناك شكرا لك عبد
الرحمن مراسل العربيه من المركز الموحد
المهمه السعوديه في الفضاء
مرحله ما بعد الالتحام يمكن اعطينا فكره
عنها قبل قليل الضيف عبد الرحمن بشكل اكثر
تفصيلا كيف ستتم وصولا الى الممر الذي
يعني يدخل من خلاله ريان وعلي الى المحطه
الدولية في البدايه اخوي خالد انا يعني
كنت انتظر هذه اللحظه عشان اقدم خالص
المباركات المقام خادم الحرمين الشريفين
العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان على يعني هذا
انجاز التاريخي اضافه الى يعني الدعم
الكبير اللي قدموه الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء
ويعني
برنامج رواد الفضاء بصوره خاصه يعني كان
في دعم لا منقطع يعني دعم كبير في يعني
يتقدم لهم بالشكر الجزيل وكذلك ارجع واقول
يعني الف مبروك على المملكه والف مبروك
مبروك على العالم العربي
اجابتها على سؤالك بعد الالتحام تفضل
المهندس ماجد في عده اشياء من واجراءات
لازم تتم منها اجراءات
على المركبه اللي هي دراغون واجراءات
موجوده على محطه الفضاء الدوليه بحيث انها
تتوافق وتتلائم البيئه الموجوده في دراغون
بالبيئه الموجوده في محطه الفضاء الدوليه
بحيث لا يكون في اي اختلاف في الضغط درجه
الحراره تكون متوافقه
الاكسجين وتزويد بالطاقه
لمركبه بحيث انها يتم ايصالها بمحطه
الفضاء الدوليه على اساس
الطاقه تكون يعني متوفره وكافيه في عده
اجراءات لما ينتون من الاجراءات هذه عاده
تبدا تعرف انهم اقتربوا من لحظه الدخول
لما تشوف رواد الفضاء في محطه الفضاء
الدوليه يبدون يضعون الكاميرات التصوير
ويترقبون لحظه فتح الباب فلما يفتح الباب
يفتح الباب اولا في محطه الفضاء الدوليه
بعدين من ثم يدخلون واحد من رواد الفضاء
ويروح عند بوابه
ويعطونهم الاشاره والسماح منهم
ينتقدون من
رواد الفضائل الموجودين وينضمون
والامارات ممتاز بالمقارنه مع مع حاله
الالتحام التي تمت لكبسوله رائد الفضاء
الاماراتي نتكلم عن التاخير لمده عشر
دقايق في الكبسوله دراغون لكن كانت كان
الوقت اطول ربما الالتحام كبسوله رائد
الفضائي الاماراتي اخذت وقت اطول اخذت وقت
اطول هناك خلل فني كان في الكبسوله
على الصوره هذه دكتور انت عندك سلم خلاه
الان هذه الكرو دراغون التحمت المطعم اللي
تحت المخروطيه هذا الكبسوله اللي فيها
رواد الفضاء
نعم الجزء اللي فوق منها المربع دائريه
الجزء اللي فوقها المظلم هذا اللي فيه
الخلايا الشمسيه ووحدات الطاقه والى اخره
وهم يدخلون مع مقدمه قطع الكروم ومن هناك
يستطيعون الدخول الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه
اللي فوق الدائريه هذه القطعه زي ما احنا
شايفين المظلم هي امتداد للمحطه هذا
امتداد
هذا اللي يكون فيه الخلايا الشمسيه
والانظمه هم ينزلوا من تحت
هم اصلا موجودين فقط في الجزء المخروطي
الابيض اللي
نزولهم يكون على الاسفل على الاسفل نزوله
بس على اساس اعرف
هذه الى الاسفل
لكن انت اخبر بالفضل دكتور لا فوق ولا تحت
طيب وبالتالي يعني بس انه المنطقه ومنطقه
المحطه اللي يتم نشاهد الان في الصوره
اجزاء منها تشوفها على اليسار في قطعه في
اجزاء موجوده على اليمين وهذه نقطه التحام
النقاط اللي موجوده لانه الان اثناء ما
احنا نتحدث في اكثر من كبسوله ملتحمه في
محطات الفضاء الدوليه في محطه
الروسيه وفي كبسوله الاحتياطيه هذول
الكبسولات يعتبرونها قوارب نجاه اذا لا
سمح الله صار فيها ظرف طارق في محطه
الفضاء الدوليه او
حريقه وما شابه لا سمح الله
يطلعون الى قوارب النجاه هذه للعوده لكوكب
الارض بالتالي هي بتكون ثابته حتى نهايه
سريعا دكتور
ايش اهميه الابحاث والتجارب العلميه التي
تتم في الفضاء اللي بيقوم فيها علي وكذلك
ريان في تجارب يعني هل الب استفاد من مثل
هذه التجارب في حالات مثلا سريعه
تمت عبر يعني سنين كثيره يعني محطه الفضاء
الدوليه الان لها تقريبا من عام
2000 لما ابتدا
فبالتالي يعني قاموا بالتجارب كثيره منها
يعني تجارب التعليميه في التجارب الصحيه
في تجارب الفيزيائيه في عده تجارب كلها
تعود فائده على الانسانيه يعني اعطيك مثال
التجربه اللي بتقوم بها ريانه ان شاء الله
في الخلايا الجذعيه هذه من مستشفى الملك
فيصل التخصصي وفي نفس الاثناء اللي ريانه
تقوم بالتجربه في محطه الفضاء الدوليه في
احدى زميلاتها تقوم بنفس التجربه على
الارض على الارض تتم المقارنه بين في
البيانات بين الاثنين ممتاز ممتاز الطريقه
هذه نستطيع يعني نشوف وش الفائده من
الاشياء كذلك ممكن نستفيد فيها التصنيع في
الفضاء وتم اثبات انك الان على الالياف
الزجاجيه الفايبر على اللي احنا نسميها
الان
حتى السماعات
اللاسلكيه كانت الفكره الاساسيه كانت
قائمه من تجربه في المحطه او في مثال على
الفايبر لما تصنع في سطح الكره الارضيه
كفاءتها تقترب الى
فوق التسعين قليل بينما اذا تم تصنيف
محترف هناك قيمه علميه مهمه لهذه الرحله
الفضائيه التي تقوم بها السعوديه الان
بالنظر الى تجربه ريانه وبالنظر كذلك الى
مهمه
جدا تطلعات المملكه
نحنا ان شاء الله نصل الى القمر والمريخ
فاذا نصل الى القمر والمريخ نستطيع ان
نوفر يعني المياه هنا كده فعمليه
الاستمطار في الجاذبيه الصغرى كانت من اهم
التجارب الفيزيائيه انا اشكرك شكر جزيل
الدكتور هيثم التويجري من المستشار في
الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء شكرا دكتور الله
يحييكم شكرا
اتمنى مؤخرا اجمال التدريبات المتعلقه
بالرحله يمكن التدريب نفسها فانه جدا مكثف
تدريباته على كيفيه التعايش داخل المحطه
الفضاء الدوليه ممن اهداف الباحثين او
العلماء والمطورين اللي على الارض يجربوا
تجاربهم هذه في الفضاء دوري الان هو اني
امثله في هذه المهمه العلميه بشكل عام
تثبت او او تمكننا من القدره على النجاح
في هذه المهمه وتعد هذه البعثات الفضائيه
هي احدى ثمار هذه الرؤيه ويوصل طموحنا
لعنان السماء
على بدء الهدنه في السودان باريس تثمن
جهود الرياض وتدعو للتطبيق كامل للبنود
علي وريان
يصلان الى المحطه الدوليه وترقب لنتائجها
رايداء الفضاء السعودية يتحدثان من الفضاء
الحلم يتحقق وشكرا على التمكين
صوره توام السيامي حسين وبسام الى الرياض
تمهيدا لعمليه الفصل المقرره لهما
موجه برد في جنوب السعوديه تعيد التساؤلات
حول المناخ موجه طقس عابره عن تغير دائم
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات